what's the deal with airplane
peanuts what's up everybody Welcome to
the Legion of skanks everybody live from
skankfest so excited I can't believe
lwis is going to fist fight Brendan sha
on I expect this and I'm on mushroom
come on Joe guys I got to be honest I'm
hard 90 of the world's best comedians
and 3,000 DieHard comedy fans all met in
Las Vegas Nevada last week for 3 Days of
the greatest most unhinged Comedy
Festival you can find anywhere on planet
Earth this video is a full recap of
skang Fest 2023 including every
highlight every moment of drama and
exclusive interviews with the comedians
themselves this is the truth about skang
Fest starting off with the insane
lineups of comedians at every single
show there's no other festival in the
world that books this killer of a lineup
it sounds like this would be a given for
any Comedy Festival but every single
person booked at skang Fest is
legitimately hilarious and there's so
many of them on the more famous side you
have guys like Mark Norman Tim Dylan
Tony hinchcliff and Ari shafir but this
Festival is far from topheavy everyone
who's hitting the stage at skang Fest
has earned the right to be there solely
based on their ability to be funny
unlike some other comedy festivals who
from time to time put hitting their
inclusion metrics above the jokes Ian
skang Fest features over 90 different
comedians if you were to say who is the
most underrated comedian at skankfest
who would that be oh my God what a
question I don't know dude I love
Brendan sagalo so much he's the [__]
[__] his podcast is breaking up but like
a phoenix he's going to Rise From the
Ashes and I'm encouraging to focus on
comedic rap he's so good at freestyling
who would you say is the most underrated
comic Here Blake Hammond from Cincinnati
Blake Hammond's so funny dude uh he
looks kind of like a little armadillo of
a man but his jokes are Rock Solid he
opened for Canan he opened for Norman in
Cincinnati yeah Blake's the most
underrated guy here for sure okay you've
never heard of him no and your whole job
is aggregating comedy content yeah yeah
yeah Blake's got a great special out by
4x3 Productions I love Blake okay check
out Blake one of the most unique Parts
about skang Fest when compared to other
festivals is that the comedians
themselves are all very accessible the
entire Festival takes place all in one
venue so everyone is together the entire
time and you start to make friends with
strangers and other comedy fans after
seeing them around a handful of times
meeting so many comedians and joke World
subscribers all in one place felt
unbelievable being at gang Fest really
makes it feel like you're part of a
larger community of Comedy fans and all
the comedians are so nice and so easy to
talk to even Legends like Doug stanh
hope are just walking around ready to
crash an interview at a moment's notice
I didn't expect you that means dud I
told my podcast producer I'm going to go
do an interview with joke world and he
was like yes yes cuz like he knows what
that means man so oh good St hopes here
here's the Twitter pole would you rather
see Burke ker finally put on a shirt
shirt or a Sam Talent put on a pair of
pants with these grotesque legs like you
should be wearing those sleeves I'm
wearing one stupid oh you are oh you're
gross you have [__] open puls that
you have to hide hey uh I'm a a big fan
of Sam talent and his book um running
the light is uh we were just talking
last night one of the best books ever
written and the follow up wo
um but the guy's got this thing where he
can't just let go I would let go of my
vintage suits if he would just put on
some trousers and don't make them in my
size bro maybe you should change sizes
that's hilarious Doug s nice to meet you
this guy's joke world I'm going to go
see Dr Drew and just say listen based on
the bloat of my head after 2 and 1/2
days of skankfest do I have a problem
problem we'll find out the answer after
these commercial messages there's no
commercials it's for YouTube you old
[__] trying to [__] get some
sponsorship for
these see now I'm canell all right I
said I'm cancel I will suck every dick
in this part thanks to Doug Stan hope we
do have a quick sponsor of today's video
my bookie Las Vegas was filled with
sports books but none of them offered a
100% first deposit bonus like my bookie
which basically means whatever amount of
money you put into bet with the first
time my buy will give you the same
amount for free only if you type in our
promo code jkw rld I've had a rough
start to the betting season so far
hammering the Bengals almost every
single week but even when you're losing
my bookie makes it better they at least
give the option for live cash outs
during the game which maybe I'll take
advantage of next time they also offer
in-game betting online casinos and easy
to sign up and cash out systems again
that's promo code JK wrld to claim your
100% cash bonus and support the channel
while you're at it now back to the video
directly after talking with us Doug Stan
hope went upstairs and chugged a cup of
his own piss on the Dr Drew show like we
mentioned before skang Fest takes place
over the course of 3 days with each day
featuring over 14 hours of Live Comedy
the best chunk of standup I personally
witnessed had to be Tim Dylan on Sunday
night where he came out on stage to do a
10-minute set and left with a Standing
Ovation people were lined up in the
hallways trying to get a glimpse of the
show throughout his entire set every
single show is packed standing room only
with even more people right outside the
door waiting for others to leave so they
can finally enter the show every
comedian gets a huge pop when they walk
out on stage the fans are so eager to
hear good jokes all day it's insane
especially because every single person
within a 10m radius of this Festival is
either on drugs looking for drugs
aggressively Ben shrinking deathly
hungover or a combination of those four
options including the comedians if
skankfest if you could describe it as
one drug what would it be oh interesting
I think it would be some weird res
search chemical that uh you can only get
off like a 53-year-old dude who lives
down at the end of the Cold attack or
like a 15-year-old on the dark web it's
something that doesn't have a name it
just has like a molecule and like a
binary code it's euphoric it's also very
daunting it it sends you on this like
wild erratic Thrill Ride cuz every
[__] time I'm on stage I want to
prove that I'm funny cuz there's so much
expectation for me to be funny after
last year and then when you get off
stage and just this like [__] violent
come down dude I really don't think that
there's a drug out there yet besides
like maybe adrenic Chrome one of the
best part about skang Fest is that it's
not just traditional standup shows and
live podcast recordings over and over
and over there's so much weird and fun
stuff going on that you don't see at any
other comedy festivals or comedy shows
like the naked roast the midnight circus
show Alis Mania which included things
like blind kickboxing musical acts or
Carnival combat's press conference
between Lis J Gomez and Tim butterly who
will be fighting each other November 4th
in St Petersburg Florida which is an
event I'll also be attending to report
on for this channel skang Fest was
filled with these type of special events
that involve comics and involve jokes
but are so uniquely tailored to this
festival and this crowd's interest so
the fans are they're great but they're a
little crazy here at skang Fest I feel
like when everyone's coming up on stage
and riffing that's the first thing
they're talking about is what's the deal
with these fans what's the craziest
thing you've seen so far this year or at
other skang fests in the past as far as
a fan just oh I can't speak to the
craziest thing I've seen with a fan but
I could certainly say the craziest thing
is uh this seems to be the legless
capital of the world it's like the
second you lose your legs they put you
in a wheelchair without breaks and just
push you to Vegas dude and I didn't know
a side effect of meth is uh basket
weaving with Palm Sunday leaves like I
don't get that dude it's not skankfest
is supposed to be the craziest party in
all of Comedy you hear all about it
online what's the craziest thing that
you've ever seen at any skankfest so
like the thing that uh most blew my mind
is that fair to say yeah sure a bunch of
like very kind and sweet people who come
up to you and they're like I really
don't want to bother you but would you
sign my book or like I saw you in Kansas
City and you were great the expectations
of this place is it's going to be a
rolling chud Factory where every uh
every guy is wearing a Tapout shirt and
their girlfriends all have black eyes
they're covering up with [__] mall
makeup but no everyone's super sweet
here and it totally blew any
expectations I had that's awesome yeah
that is crazy like I'm a happily married
man I'm not sniffing around late night
like I don't know all these like crazy
stories like I don't I'm not privy to
them cuz I'm playing ass with Dan Soder
or giving Ian fance a piggyback ride
like to be able to hang out with all
these people that I barely see ever is
so special as far as the biggest moments
from the festival moving forward the
fighter and the kid live show was the
most popular moment from skang Fest on
the internet everyone was so curious to
see how Brendan shop and Brian Callen
finally at skang Fest would actually
play out especially after it almost
didn't happen due to Brian's flight
getting canceled in New York luckily the
event was rescheduled for a few hours
later Brian Callen was able to arrive on
time and the whole thing went relatively
well and the fighter and the kid crew
definitely gained some respect from
everyone in attendance Brendan was
owning up to jokes made at his expense
instead of being defensive like people
predicted and really the key moment
where everyone loosened up and started
to have a good time seemed to be when
Lewis asked Brendan why everyone hates
him so much and someone from the crowd
yelled out to Lewis you started it the
most popular moment around the actual
Festival has to be the Jo D Roa
transgender hand job Saga which happened
on the first show of the first day and
was a talk of the Fest from there on out
the IAL story of what happened changes
every time you hear it but the key
details seemed to be there was a
transgender audience member at the
Legion of skanks broadcast who claimed
they could suck their own dick on stage
so they sent Joe D Roa into the bathroom
to get her penis hard and they never
came back out almost every live show for
the rest of the week and featured at
least one or two Joe D Roa transgender
hand job jokes and honestly he didn't
seem too phased by it reinforcing that
literally anything goes at skankfest Joe
D roza and the fighter and the kid may
have been amongst the most exciting
parts of skang Fest but the most
disappointing moment from this entire
weekend seems to be unanimous for almost
everyone in attendance the Shane Gillis
noow apparently Shane not only had
flight troubles but was reportedly very
sick and stuck in New York without a
voice which is definitely understandable
for Shane but sucks for anyone who
bought a ticket and made this trip
solely for a chance to see the young
bull on stage is everyone else at Shane
Gillis well he's not here oh yeah whoops
so many [__] fat guys are
disappointed that Shane's not here I
heard someone fake announc that was
coming out next and the crowd went nuts
and then some random I don't know who it
was but someone just had to go out there
after the crowd is so disappointed and
like that sucks for that guy What a
wicked thing to do for that fourth year
open micer from Memphis also by the way
thank you to Dick's Last Resort for
making a statue of me with the massive
amounts of Comedy events happening over
the course of just 3 days you'd think
that the comedians would need to repeat
material way more often throughout the
142 different shows but most of the
comics did a great job being aware that
people may have just seen them on a
different stage hours or minutes before
almost every set started off by mixing
in some crowd work or riffing about Las
Vegas and the festival as a whole the
pure debauchery of this Festival fits in
perfectly with the vibe of Las Vegas
this was the seventh skankfest of all
time and the second year in a row it's
taking place in Old Vegas on Fremont
Street there's always a chance skang
Fest could return to Las Vegas one day
but for next year it's already been
confirmed that skang Fest 2024 will take
place in Tampa Florida what city would
you think skankfest would really prosper
in next I don't know man I'm I'm New
York through and through I say bring it
back to where it started we need a
skankfest New York it's bigger than ever
[__] we can find the venue let's
[__] do it let's go let's take it
back to the [__] start Pensacola
Florida dude if they could do this on
the beach or like maybe like in some
like War torn African like protectorate
where there's literally no laws and we
can like actually buy and sell people
you know but in America Pensacola
Florida would be great awesome Pensacola
I love Pensacola bro do you really oh
yeah dude like no one's on the beach for
like 10 months of the year and you can
just drink Yingling on the beach and
like watch people suck each other off
down the down the sand it's very nice
sounds like a good time to me from a fan
perspective it was a lot of walking and
standing the first day you get a
schedule like this a pamphlet with all
the shows that are happening there's
usually three or four different things
going on at once so you look through the
schedule and decide which shows you want
to go to based on what looks best to you
however the problem that often occurs is
everyone wants to go to the same shows
and it creates a massive line even after
the room hits capacity there's always
people waiting to go in as soon as other
people come out just so they can go
stand in the back seriously there is so
much standing this problem did seem to
slowly Fade Away throughout the weekend
I don't know if I just got better at
learning how to navigate skankfest or if
people were slowly dying with each
passing day but either way things got a
lot smoother from start to finish the
late shows were always a bit lighter
than midday because a huge portion of
skang fans goes was super hard around
noon and rarely make it to the midnight
showings the festival being super
crowded was a cool thing it just would
have been nice to know what to expect
beforehand I even saw one dude carrying
around his own lawn chair from show to
show which is by far the best skankfest
hack that I've seen attending Live
Comedy is awesome but watching standup
and live podcasts for 10 to 12 hours on
your feet the entire time isn't
something anybody wants to do what lwis
Rebecca and Christine have been able to
build at skankfest is unreal it truly is
the All-Star Game for comedy fans this
video was a massive review of the
festival as a whole but if you'd like to
hear more about my personal experience
at skankfest including which shows I
ended up going to and my favorite
moments you can find that video on our
second Channel clip World in a couple of
days we'll also be posting the full
versions of our interviews with Ian
fance and Sam Talent somewhere soon
other than that thank you so much for
watching this entire video and please be
sure to subscribe it's completely
free at joke
world that's did it
world and the world is
wld that's a great uh YouTube channel
joke World check it out